like I'm smarter now so I've learned  from the mistakes that I made and and  I've always said  the only way a man becomes I say the  only way one of the ways that men become  men is going through tough times is  going through things that we don't think  we're going to go through and we think  we're invincible and then life says haha  [ __ ] you [ __ ] here you go here's  a curveball right and I think that tough  times produce tough people I think easy  times produce soft people so I would say  that any man that's gone through  something tough in his life  he's probably like a man that people  would want to be around and and he's  speaking like that because he's gone  through those things